ciao scusate ti mando la odio ma per
questo tanto sapere se le dice tutti 14
messaggi cambiato se non eletti
tranquillo non c'è problema anche perché
modulo che sarà pronto famiglia e non
farai quando il telefono e mente visto
che siamo ci dirà dieci giorni non si fa
sentire da 9 vorremmo capire se anche tu
eri provato le stesse emozioni ti dico
io l'ho sentito l'ho sentito bello forse
c'è il trasporto tra di noi quindi
fu anche perché siamo già natale e
quindi volevo attimo organizzarmi per
capodanno con calma ecco però volevo
organizzarli e mi hanno evitato una
festa in baita molto molto bella ma
volevo prima appunto sentite perché
ovviamente riferimento sono con te però
ecco come sapere due minuti e mezzo di
audio scusami vedi non farvi sapere ciao
ciao baci ma se quasi